Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Jakob Olden. Ich bin Assistenzarzt hier auf dieser Station.
Und jetzt möchte ich gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch füllen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja.
Okay, dann bräuchte ich zuerst ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen.
Beginnen wir mit Ihrem Namen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Hans-Peter Lohmann.
Hans? Habt ihr es sein oder alles nachmachen?
Peter ist der Vorname H-A-N-S, dann Minus.
Peter?
P-E-T-E-R. Hans-Peter, das ist der Vorname. Und Lohmann. L-O-H-M-A-N-N. Lohmann.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen, Herr Lohmann. Können Sie mir bitte sagen, wie alt Sie sind?
Ich bin 58. Können Sie mir genau sagen, wann sind Sie geworden?
Ja, am 19. März 1967.
67. Okay, wie groß Sie sind, Herr Lohmann?
Ich bin 1,83 m.
Dankeschön. Und Herr Lohmann, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was führt Sie denn zu uns heute?
Ja, seit ungefähr drei Wochen merke ich, dass ich ganz schlecht schlafe.
Dass ich nervös bin. Unruhig. Ich bin sehr schnell gereizt.
Meine Ehefrau sagt, ich sei sehr schnell, würde ich aggressiv werden.
Das kennt sie so nicht. Das war früher nicht.
Ja, das ist so seit drei Wochen.
Okay. Vor drei Wochen haben Sie keine, welche werden für die Nervosität oder ergelichbar?
Nein, vor drei Wochen war ich ziemlich ausgeglichen und ruhig.
Okay.
Sie sagt, alle wundern sich. Meine Ehefrau sagt, was ist passiert?
Du hast dich so verändert.
Ja.
Erinnern Sie sich in der letzten Zeit eine Traumarkt oder etwas Verletzungen?
Nein, ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt.
Oder ich war jetzt auch dicht in letzter Zeit schwer krank, oder hatte kein Fieber oder so. Nein.
Fieber keine. Okay.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie bemerkt, die Gewicht zugehen oder abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe in den letzten vier Wochen ungefähr sechs Kilogramm verloren, angewicht.
In den vier Wochen, ja.
Okay. Leiden Sie an nachtschweiß? Nächliche Schweizer?
Ich bin nicht aufgefallen. Aber wie gesagt, ich liege nachts ganz lange wach, weil ich schlecht schlafe,
aber so richtig nachts Schweiß habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Sie haben schlafschturung. Okay. Und Sie sind nervös.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, übel ist mir nicht.
Haben Sie Verdauungsbeschwerden?
Nein.
Ich, in den letzten Wochen, muss ich häufiger auf Toilette ab, häufiger Stuhlgang.
Normalerweise habe ich jeden einmal pro Tag Stuhlgang, aber in den letzten Wochen mehrfach, dreimal am Tag, das ist anders geworden.
Okay. Wie sieht Ihre Stuhl aus? Ist normal oder dünn oder flüssiger?
Nein, der Stuhlgang sieht eigentlich normal aus.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Problem beim Wasserlassen?
Ich muss ein bis zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette auf Wasser lassen. Das muss ich aber schon lange.
Das ist bestimmt schon fünf, sechs Jahre so. Da war ich auch schon mal bei der Untersuchung beim Urlogen.
Aber da war nichts Auffälliges beim Wasserlassen.
Ich habe allerdings Prostattackazinom.
2023 ist er entdeckt worden. Da bin ich operiert worden und auch bestrahlt worden.
Vor acht Wochen war ich zur Kontrolle beim Urlogen.
Der hat dann auch noch eine Computertomographie veranlasst vom Bauch. Aber es war alles soweit in Ordnung.
Okay. Sie haben im Alter von 32 Jahren Prostattackazinom?
Nein, nicht von 32 Jahren, vor zwei Jahren.
2023, also 2023. Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich die Operation und auch die Bestrahlung.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie auch Chemo?
Nein, ist zwar bestrahlt worden und es ist operiert worden.
Die Operation ist komplikationlos.
Das war alles soweit gut.
Okay. Und außer Prostattackazinom, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich an der Nase operiert wegen Polypen.
An der Nasenschleimhaut. Da wurden die Polypen entfernt.
Und im Alter von 28 Jahren hatte ich eine Meniscus-Operation durch eine Kniespiegelung.
Im Alter von 28 Jahren.
Da hatte ich eine Meniscus-Operation.
Da wurde ein Teil des linken Meniscus entfernt durch eine Spiegelung.
Also ist das gemacht worden, mit einer Kniespiegelung.
Verstehe ich.
Wir haben keine Verdienstbeschwerte und seit drei Wochen, die ihre Beschwerte auftreten.
Und jetzt möchte ich fragen, Ihre Medikation, nehmen Sie Ihre gelbeste Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich habe seit vier Jahren auch hohen Blutdruck.
Und dann nehme ich Rami-Pril ein, Rami-Pril-5.
Morgens eine Tablette und abends. Und dann nehme ich auch noch Bisoprolol.
Wie sehen Sie das?
Ja, 5 steht dahinter.
Da nehme ich auch morgens eine und abends eine Tablette.
Und dann habe ich noch hohe Harnsäure.
Seit sechs Jahren nehme ich auch eine Tablette ein.
Hier heißt Allopurinol.
300 steht dahinter. Allopurinol 300.
Da nehme ich morgens eine halbe Tablette.
Okay.
Und reagieren Sie etwas allergisch auf?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Ich habe mal ein Pilzmittel genommen.
Das habe ich mir notiert.
Der Wirkstoff heißt Terbenafin.
Da bin ich allergisch drauf.
Da habe ich Ausschlag bekommen und Hautrötung.
Dann haben wir das schnell wieder abgesetzt.
Da sollte ich einnehmen wegen Fusspilz.
Ist das neue oder so früher?
Das war früher. Das war vor 10 Jahren.
Jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie.
Ihre Eltern noch einnehmen?
Ja, mein Vater ist 85 Jahre alt.
Er hat Alterszucker.
Er hatte 2005, im Jahr 2005, auch Postata Krebs.
Aber das ist, er hat Vater, wurde behandelt?
Ja, dem geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Er hat wohl keine Probleme mehr mit.
Die Mutter, die ist 83 Jahre alt.
Bei der Mutter wurde vor, dann war das jetzt 10 Jahren.
Er hat eine künstliche Hüfte.
Rechts operiert, also bekam eine neue Hüfte.
Vor 12 Jahren bekam sie einen Herzschrittmacher.
Wegen Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Vor 20 Jahren.
Vor 12 Jahren.
Dann habe ich noch eine Schwester.
60 Jahre alt.
Er hatte vor 7 Jahren, also 2018, die Schwester Nierenkrebs.
Da wurde die Niere ganz entfernt.
Das war rechts.
Da geht es aber wieder ganz gut.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt.
Er hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und der hat grauen Starr.
Da muss er demnächst operiert werden.
Er hat wohl neue Linsen in die Augen.
Rechts, ja.
Und Starr beide Seiten.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt.
Ja, der Bruder ist 61.
Okay.
Ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen über ihre Leversgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Lohmann?
Ja, ich rauche.
Ich rauche ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag.
Das ist auch schon ziemlich lange. 30 Jahre.
Über 30 Jahre, ja.
Okay.
Ich empfehle Ihnen die Rauchen.
Abgrattet.
Ja, das sagen alle.
Meine Frau sagt das.
Meine Familie sagt das.
Ich habe noch keine Motivation gehabt.
Haben Sie schon versucht?
Ja, ich habe schon versucht.
Mit Nikotin, Kaugummi und der Krankenkasse.
Einen Kurs gemacht.
Aber das hat bisher noch nicht geholfen.
Ich möchte, dass es nicht einfach ist.
Ich glaube, ich bin noch nicht so weit.
Okay.
Herr Lohmann, können Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends so eine Flasche Bier.
Und nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, keine Drogen.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Lohmann?
Ich bin Tischler.
Tischler?
Seit wann machen Sie diese Werbung?
Seit meinem 16. Lebensjahr habe ich die Ausbildung gemacht.
Und ja, es arbeite ich schon lange in der
Tischlerei. Das macht mir Spaß.
Okay.
Macht ich weiß, ich gehe davon aus, Sie sind zufrieden mit
Ihrem Beruf her?
Ja, bis auf die letzten drei Wochen, wo es mir nicht so gut geht.
Verstehe ich.
Nervös war und so unruhig.
Okay.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, zwei Töchter.
Die sind 30 Jahre alt und 32 Jahre.
Die sind gesund.
Okay, wunderbar.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit der Frau Ehrfrau, die Töchter von online.
Okay.
Ich guck mal noch.
Haben Sie bemerkt, Herr Lohmann,
Geschwollung, im Heißgeschwollung?
Nein, nein, habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Haben Sie bemerkt auch im Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wobei, mein Nachbar sagte zu mir, du nimmst ja dieses eine
Medikament ein.
Ich glaube, das ist dieses Bisoprolol.
Das bremst ja so ein bisschen den Puls.
Das herrn.
Aber Herzklopfen, so habe ich direkt, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe aber sehr viel Appetit.
Trotzdem, Sie haben 6 kg abgenommen.
Ja.
In der Nacht waren Sie auf zum Essen?
Nein, in der Nacht esse ich nicht.
Da trägt ich höchstens mal Wasser.
Aber Essen tue ich nachts nicht.
Ich lege dann im Bett und kann nicht schlafen
und drehe mich hin und her.
Aber ich stehe nicht auf, um etwas zu essen.
Nein.
Okay.
Hallo, Mann.
Ich habe nun alle wichtigen Informationen notiert.
Haben Sie etwas hinzufügen oder möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Ja, das kann ich denn haben.
Das macht mir schon jetzt Sorgen.
Eigentlich habe ich ein paar Gedanken, ein paar Ideen.
Das hätte das auch Prostatakarsinon.
Könnte sein, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Genau.
Ja, zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Okay.
Nach ein paar apparative Diagnostik durchführen oder bestellen.
Ja.
Danach vielleicht kann man genau etwas sagen.
Gut.
Dann können wir das so machen. Prima.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt Zeit, eine Minute, nicht so lange wie in der Prüfung.
Die Patientensprache in die Fachsprache zu übersetzen.
Und vielleicht gibt es noch Fragen von Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Vielleicht haben wir noch etwas, vielleicht vergessen oder ist etwas nicht verstanden worden.
Bitte fragen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie Wärme Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Umverträglichkeit?
Oder Haareunfall?
Haareausfall?
Ja, also Wärme, also nachts zum Beispiel, da liege ich oft da mit einer ganz dünnen Bettecke nur.
Also, und Haarausfall habe ich nicht.
Ne, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe aber ohnehin relativ wenig Haare, inzwischen, so dass ich das nicht so bemerkt habe.
Aber Wärme kann ich nicht so gut ab.
Und haben Sie Zittern und Schwindeln?
Windel habe ich nicht.
Zittern ist mir jetzt, ja, es kann sein, dass ich ein bisschen mehr Zittern habe,
aber ich merke das kaum, weil ich gar nicht mehr so groß schreibe.
Ich habe mehr geschrieben, aber heute mache ich, wenn ich etwas mache am Computer,
da tippe ich, fällt mir das nicht so auf.
Aber richtig starkes Zittern habe ich nicht.
Vielen Dank.
Darf ich fragen?
Ist Ihnen hervortretende Augen aufgefallen?
Hervortretende Augen ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, nein.
Und außerdem ist Ihnen vielleicht eine Furchte,
Ihnen Händehaut aufgefallen?
Ja, wenn Sie das so sagen, sind meine Hände schon irgendwie etwas wärmer und feuchter als sonst.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Okay, danke schon.
Haben Sie Konzentration gestohlen?
Ja, inzwischen ja, weil ich ja auch so schlecht schlafe und ich fühle mich dann auch nicht mehr erholt.
Also, ja, ich möchte jetzt zum Beispiel auch, ich fahre sonst immer gerne Auto,
aber das mag ich jetzt gar nicht so, weil das alles mich zu sehr anstrengt im Augenblick.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, ich habe Schluckbeschwerden nicht.
Bein-Ödem?
Was heißt Ödem?
Ist Ihnen am Bein Schwellungen aufgefallen?
Bein-Ödem?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege jetzt 72 Kilo.
Ich habe sonst immer eher 78, 79 Kilo geworden.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die Aufmerksamkeit Orientierungslosigkeit?
Orientierungslosigkeit nicht, aber eben ich kann mich nicht so gut konzentrieren
und ich fühle mich schnell eben auch so seelisch erschöpft.
Okay, gedacht nicht verlöst zum Beispiel?
Nein.
Nein, das nicht.
Haben Sie höchststörungen oder sehstörungen oder Sprechstörungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Oder verspülen Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Missenfindungen wie ein Krippen?
Nein?
Nein.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie sich Globusgefühl, eine andere Kollegin hat gefragt, aber schon gefragt?
Globusgefühl heißt Klos, ein Klosgefühl im Hals, wie ein Klos.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber gleich eine Kollegin hat gefragt, Schluck beschweren.
Ja, ja, Schluck beschweren oder dicke Halsschwellung, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt, aber nein, erst einmal.
Sie haben gesagt, vor einem Monat eine Tomografie gemacht.
Ja, vor ungefähr knapp acht Wochen wurde eine Computer-Tomografie gemacht.
Gleichzeitig haben Sie Blutuntersuchungen, zum Beispiel Troid-Untersuchungen gemacht.
Also vor dieser Computer-Tomografie wurde etwas Blut abgenommen, das stimmt.
Und da hat man gesagt, man kann die Untersuchung machen.
Ist alles gut so weit, aber nach der Untersuchung wurde das Blut nicht kontrolliert.
Diese Tomografie ist mit Kontrastmittel durchgeführt, oder?
Ja, ja, ich habe da so etwas bekommen, so ein Kontrastmittel.
Ja, das stimmt.
Vielen Dank.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt, aber können wir erst als Gespräch...
Von mir aus können wir anfangen.
Bitte schön, Jakob.
Guten Tag Herr Oberast.
Haben Sie eine große Zeit für mich?
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, deswegen möchte ich das vorstellen.
Ja, aber ich...
Es handelt sich um Hans-Peter Lohmann.
Herr Lohmann ist 58-jährige Patient.
Und er ist 72 kg und 1,83 m.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, er muss das jetzt werden.
Und deswegen habe er eine OP- und Strahlungstherapie.
Ja, Radiazio, kannst du ruhig sagen Radiazio.
Okay.
Hat der Patient normalen Stuhlgang, oder hat er da irgendetwas bemerkt?
Eigentlich nicht.
Er habe keine Beschwerden beim Wasser lassen, aber er habe ihm seit letzter Woche...
Er hatte ein paar Probleme beim Stuhlgang.
In letzter Woche pro Tag 3 Mal pro Tag Stuhlgang.
Aber die Stuhl sieht normal aus.
Und normal hat er nur einmal am Tag Stuhlgang?
Ja, vorher, vor 1 Woche.
Die Stuhlgang ist normal.
Ich habe jetzt eine erhöhte Stuhlfrequenz.
3 Mal pro Tag.
Das ist verändert gegenüber früher.
Okay.
Ausher dem...
Ausher dem die Patientin sagt, er habe Tremor und Konzentration Probleme wegen des Insomnia.
Okay.
Wegen der Insomnia.
Und Traumodokumfall wurde verneint.
Exotarmus auch wurde verneint.
Anfordererkrankungen sind arterielle Hypertonie und fraglich Arthritisurica bekannt.
Ja, Arthritisurica, der Patient sagt, er hat hohe Harnsäurewerte.
Da würden wir sagen, er hat eine Hyperurikemi.
Hyperurikemi.
Bisher wohl noch ohne Arthritis, also ohne Podagra oder ohne Gichtanfall.
Bis er hat hohe Harnsäure.
Das ist erstmal sein Labor.
Was nimmt er dagegen ein?
Nehmt er Medikamente?
Ja, er nimmt gegen arterielle Hypertonie, Ramipril und bisoprolöl.
Ramipril ist 5 mg und bisoprolöl auch 5 mg.
Die beiden Medikamente nimmt der Patient morgens und abends.
Und wegen Hyperurikemi nehmen alle Patienten 300 mg, aber nur halbe Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Besteht eine Wärmeintoleranz?
Ja, bei der Patientin bestätigt eine Wärmeintoleranz, besonders nachts.
Okay.
Und vor 10 Jahren hatte der Patient Fußpils, deswegen Tabletten, die allergisch äußerst durchs Eck sehen.
Man kann sagen, es besteht offenkundig eine Medikamentenallergie auf Tabelnafin oder Unverträglichkeit.
Das würde als Information erst mal reichen.
Gut, ich fasse mal kurz zusammen, was Sie mir berichtet haben.
Also, der Herr Lohmann ist 58 Jahre alt, er klagt seit ungefähr 3 Wochen über Insomnie,
und Konzentrationsstörungen auch über aggressive Reaktionen gegenüber der Ehefrau wohl.
Ist wohl zu hören, er hat kein Fieber, er hat sehr guten Appetit und er hat aber eine Gewichtsabnahme.
Ja.
Wie hoch war die Gewichtsabnahme nochmal?
Ich habe es nicht...
Ja, er hat 6 kg abgenommen in 4 Wochen.
Ja, okay.
Gab es irgendwas Auffälliges in den letzten Wochen bei den Patienten?
Gab es ein Infekt?
Gab es irgendeine Untersuchung?
Was auch immer?
Hab ich nicht richtig verstanden, aber wir können es nochmal...
Ja, der Patient, wann, die sagen, er hat ein Prostatakatinomen.
Er ist Diagnose 2023.
Er ist mit Radiation behandelt worden.
Und wann war die letzte Nachsorgeuntersuchung?
Vor 8 Monaten.
Ach, 8 Wochen.
Wochen?
Vor 8 Wochen bei den Patienten eine City durchgeführt.
Er wurde durchgeführt.
Im City sieht alles gut aus.
Bei den Patienten wurde auch Blut abgenommen.
Aber nach der Blut, die Patienten mit dem Patientin nicht gebrachten.
Also nach der Computertomographie wurde das Blut nicht kontrolliert.
Ja.
Vorher.
Okay.
Gut, ist der Patient schon mal sonst operiert worden außerhalb der Prostate OP?
Vor Operationen gab es an, dass Patienten im Menusküs OP, Artroskopik, Menusküs Entfernung...
Ja, Teilresekzion.
Teilresekzion.
Teilresekzion durchgeführt wurde.
Und auch im Kindheit wurde Nasenpolip Entfernung.
Ja, Polyposis Nasi, kann man sagen, oder Nasenpolipen, wurde eine Polypenentfernung gemacht.
Okay.
Gut, gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten, Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten?
Ja, Risikofaktoren beim Familienanamnese.
Okay.
Bei der Vater gibt es auch Prostatakarsinon.
Und bei der Vater auch Diabetes, leider an Diabetes-Menutostypes 2.
Okay.
Und bei der Mutter gibt es auch Herschrittmacher, Pace Marker, wurde implantiert bei der Mutter.
Ja.
Und auch rechtsseits gehebt, implantiert beim Mutter, bei der Mutter auch.
Ja, da wurde total die Hüfte.
Total endopro, endopro-dese.
Wissen Sie die Ursache, was ist die häufigste Ursache für eine Hüfte?
Ostioporose, knachenschönt.
Arthrose, Koksarthrose.
Meistens Koksarthrose ist die Hüftgelenksarthrose.
Ja, Küftgelenksarthrose, das ist die häufigste Ursache für eine total endopro-dese, eine Hüfttap zum Beispiel.
Ostioporose ist da eher ein bisschen sekundär, aber die Hauptursache ist die Arthrose, die Koksarthrose.
Kennen Sie den Begriff der Kniearthrose, Kniegelenks?
Unarthrose.
Genau, sehr gut. Alles gut.
Gut, also die Mutter hat die Hüfttap vor einigen Jahren gehabt, sie hat einen Pace Maker.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, er hat eine Schwester und ein Bruder. Schwester ist 60 Jahre alt, die Bruder ist 61 Jahre alt.
Der Bruder hat der Regen des Katarags operiert.
Wird, wird. Der Bruder hat einen Katarakt beidseits und wird demnächst operiert in naher Zukunft.
Was hat der Bruder noch?
Der Bruder hat auch Ateielle Hypertonie.
Ja, Ateielle Hypertonie und er hat einen beidseitigen grauen Starr, ein Katarakt, der demnächst operiert wird.
Okay, und die Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ich war da vor sieben Jahren wegen des Nierenkarzinom, eine OP gehabt, die OP Nierenentfernung.
Ja, wie nennt sich das? Fachmedizinisch?
Nefrectomy.
Nefrectomy, genau, eine Nefrectomy.
Man kann sagen, es erfolgte eine Tumornefrectomy.
Da wurde die ganze Niere in Toto entfernt.
Gut, da haben wir ja viele Informationen.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die Beschwerden und die anamästischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Hypertiose und auch Tumornefektorikgeschwurz.
Prostatakarsinometastase?
Ja, als Differenzialdiagnose, ja, okay, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Gut, was sind so für Sie die Leitsymptome der Hypertiose?
Die Nervosität und Insomnia, auch Tremor und 6 kg Abgenauung und Gewichtverlust.
Man kann in diesem Falle wahrscheinlich sprechen von der Diagnose einer Hypertiose, einer Faktizia.
Also, wodurch hervorgerufen, wahrscheinlich durch die Kontrastmittelgabe bei der Computertomographie.
Der Patient hat ja erwähnt, er hat eine Computertomographie gehabt.
Es wurde kurz gefragt vom Kollegen auch wahrscheinlich mit Kontrastmittel.
Ja, der Patient hat Kontrastmittel bekommen.
Da muss man davon ausgehen, dass das Kontrastmittel induziert ist.
Und dadurch, das kann ja einige Tage und Wochen erst später auftreten, dass es dann zu einer Hypertiose kommt.
Es ist nicht so selten, dass nach Kontrastmittelgabe und Jodexposition so etwas passiert.
Da wird der TSH-Wert vor der Untersuchung gemessen.
Der war normal, aber es kann sein, dass durch diese starke Jodexposition der Patient jetzt in eine Hypertiose geraten ist.
Viele klinische Anzeichen sprechen dafür.
Auch der gute Appetit, der Heißhunger, die höhrt die Stuhlfrequenz, die Wärmeintoleranz, der Tremor, die vielleicht feuchten Hände,
muss nicht unbedingt einen Exos-Exoftalmus haben.
Das muss ja nicht klassisch so sein.
Gegen ein metastasierendes Prostatakatzinom spricht für mich diese Unruhezustände,
die Aggressivität, die Schlaflosigkeit, der gute Appetit.
Aber natürlich muss man trotzdem das Prostatakatzinom im Auge behalten.
Auch wenn vor acht Wochen die Untersuchungen, was gemacht worden ist, erstmal in Ordnung waren.
Aber das gehört zur Abklärungsdiagnostik, denke ich, dazu.
Aber vorrangig wahrscheinlich handelt es sich um eine Hypertiose.
Gut, ja, vielen Dank. Das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Sie haben das sehr strukturiert gemacht.
Ich habe Sie sehr gut verstanden.
Sie haben auch die wesentlichen Fachbegriffe gebracht.
Das fand ich gut.
Da üben Sie noch ein bisschen weiter und haben Sie sich schon angemeldet zur Prüfung?
Ja.